[Music]
first of all thanks for inviting me to
do my fest and this has been really good
fun for me and i wish i would
have come before to tomorrow theoretical
physics conferences because it's
really interesting to to talk to people
here and
there should be more more of stuff like
this and i should say mike is the person
who brought
some
sort of machine learning for physics
people to the aitp conference to the
artificial intelligence and theorem
proving conference
so so if you are at least a bit
into into these topics then then please
join our crowd you we will see that we
are friendly and happy to engage
mathematicians and physicists and
discuss with them
how is it that you can do science and
the machines cannot
so
oh
i will
be because christian already gave
a lot of
the the setting
i may sort of skip
over
quite a lot of the propaganda and just
go
very quickly to the demo
to the demos but let me just sort of
try to
say something about
the general
uh
plan here which
so sort of is captured by
to some extent by
this uh picture from a famous books
about the
life of bertrand russell called logie
comics which i
definitely uh
recommend to anybody who wants to learn
about
the the sort of um
uh revolution in
in the foundations of math that that
happened in the beginning of
the 20th century
uh so so that there is this
dream which is
sort of attributed to leibniz uh but but
like they're very crazy people even
before leibniz
to
to sort of uh
have mechanical means how to
how to resolve
all sorts of disputes like this example
is like some accountants who just
compute and they
because they can compute they can
compare their results and find the
mistakes and and find out who is right
and and his dream is to to extend this
to to everything right like to
to
all of math and physics and like law and
and
uh and russell
who was
one of the people who
was uh
in in this in very much involved in this
process of bringing mathematics to
sort of
formal symbolic level was sort of very
much uh in inspired by
by this dream and like
uh
like here
they say like what does it mean that you
didn't
uh
didn't achieve uh leibniz dream and
i would say
a lot of what we are doing and people
before us were doing like gilbert etc
is uh
inspired by by this crazy dream that uh
go goes back
such a long time and
uh
like we we don't know like
what it takes but like especially with
all these combinations of learning and
uh
the the formal uh setting where we sort
of can play
basically play some sort of game like
this with goal and with chess
you you can play a game and you can
learn from the rules and
what what the formalism gives us is a
similar much more complicated game
that sort of involves all of math
basically and if you believe that
physics can be embedded into math than
all of physics right or at least some
parts of physics so so that that's the
sort of current
uh approach to uh my approach to to
to this dream
and like like this is the slide where i
sort of repeat it so so
when we are doing math and science
we do a lot of deduction a lot of like
complicated like reasoning chains where
we apply one more respondents after
another etc etc
and but we also
learn from what we are doing like we uh
we find patterns
uh
we have a lot of knowledge and
uh we sort of learn how to steer through
we will learn how to create new concepts
new new abstractions etc etc
and like
one one way how to sort of start to
emulate this on computers
is to take these big libraries of formal
mathematics which are today like
reasonably big as you already heard from
christian
and at least
try to
sort of learn how to play play the game
there like if
if we learn how to play the game there
then it's already like a crazy big
success because some of the theorems
that have been formalized and i guess
you will hear from
patrick
are becoming really like a research uh
research level
uh math today so so just achieving this
would be really
very a very interesting
thing
and another
another funny picture from from this
book that i really like
so so many of you are physicists
and
what
i should say like that
happened as part of this
process of
bringing mathematics to to formal
foundations
was
that people like gilbert who were
the
prophets of of of the new new new era
were met with a lot of resistance from
people at least as good as as hilbert
like people like pankara
who who sort of
wouldn't buy into it
exactly like for for for this
for this reason that they sort of saw
and couldn't sort of grasp the mismatch
between the very low level logical
uh layer
on on which like people like russell and
fraga and hilbert they're
proposing to put math and and the way
like he was
doing math like like the sort of
uh very
very very intuitive uh
so so like some of you might might know
this right like he
uh he has this uh
science and method and
he he says that like mathematics isn't
just deduction right and
what does it mean like he may mean like
or so all sorts of things by induction
like the
thing that we call conjecturing today or
like really generalization from examples
etc etc
oh
and like i'll just mention one more guy
like so
uh
so
in in some sense like
from
let's say physicists and
quite often from mathematicians like uh
in
like most of the last century
we heard that like
proving hard mathematical theorems
like you you had people like penrose who
would even claim that there is some
gadolian uh reason
while humans are better than
whatever ais or
computers and have to be better
and
the the interesting
person in in this sort of
debate
is a student
because like he he is the guy who
basically proved
uh early in in the 30s
uh
the the
sort of
enchants problem the the
sort of the halting problem and and it's
uh so sort of extension
to to undecidability of things like any
reasonable mathematics you you cannot
have a
terminating
algorithm that will tell you whether a
theorem is provable or unprovable like
like these are this is the line of
distraction that that sort of
was unleashed upon the hilbert
program of of of doing
all this like having all these um
series of uh
mechanic procedures for for deciding
more and more mathematics uh
uh but like
during himself like uh during the war
went into
a lot of statistical ai you you could
say today he basically defined the ai
field in in his 1950
paper where he defines the turing test
and where he
brings all all these reasons um to to
the sort of naysayers
why computers
can think like what does it mean that
computers can think
and
why why he doesn't see any of the
objections like
that for example came later from people
like penrose
that
computers
wouldn't be able to sort of
learn learn these things uh that that
humans are doing and what's even funnier
that in this like sort of foundational
ai paper
the last chapter is on learning machines
so so if any of you think that machine
learning is some
recent 2015 craziness like 3 1950 turing
where he
he basically in some sense
uh if you sort of drive it stretch it a
bit he sort of predicts the alpha zero
thing like this sort of self self
learning playing chess and learning
learning uh from that
oh
so i'll skip a lot of this
uh so so you you sort of heard from
christian already some some bits about
like what what is formal
uh mathematics so so it's this
process
started foreign but fraga had bucks in
his logic got destroyed by russell
russell did it for real then it was too
complicated so there was like a series
of refinements of the logical
foundations
ending up
with i know some reasonable set theory
type theory
lambda calculus iodologically like all
these are some sort of valid uh
foundations for formal mathematics today
and uh
i would say another funny remark is that
the first ai
uh ai program or like at least if you if
you read into the history is actually a
theorem theory by uh by new orleans
simon this this logic and theorist and
again like to today's impression
of what if you ask a person on a screen
what they say
they will tell you it's the neural
networks right like when when i started
it was like
logic theorists
uh
and so so when
these uh
um
the these people who sort of put
put math basically into symbolic
logic also invented computers by by some
some sort of accident like during
during the find the universal turing
machine to show that it cannot
cannot do something basically so so so
it's like
a
theoretical construction initially but
then
actually they started to build them
right everybody
knows this
and
on top of that like in in the 60s
uh people like
the brown
and then late
creating autumn off um
and then robin milner and andre tributes
and
other people in the 60s and 70s
started to really
take this seriously
say well
what prevents us
to really have a lot of mathematics
formally expressed and proof checked on
on computers and the the field sort of
went on and on and for a long time it
was sort of in this battle with
mathematicians who sort of didn't
believe it in the same way as poincare
didn't like
hilbert
uh so so so that's sort of one one
branch of of of this like uh trend uh
like started basically by fraga
and then then the other like even
[Music]
the the sort of more ai trend is this
automated here improving like again like
starting with this logic series
basically
where
mostly in the 60s but already in the 50s
uh people really started to think about
like
can we use these computers to get proofs
of complicated mathematical
conjectures
theorems
and
it's it's sort of a pretty old classical
part of the year i was with all these
systems like other vampire each pass and
pure 9 et cetera
and
a lot of that sort of didn't succeed in
some
crazy way
but
the there are
sort of limited uh successes so so for
example sub solving like prepositional
uh theorem pulling
is today
you you can say it's super human
basically if you if you have a problem
in prepositional logic
you you can do with these system
systems really crazy things like they
are
extremely well uh engineered
the heuristics there are very very good
like
improving them by some deep learning is
near to impossible because of how good
are the sort of high high level
heuristics there
and and people actually use them for
doing some some like very
combinatorial discrete
problems uh today
uh
so what uh what i started to do long ago
for my master's thesis is to basically
do
do this um
like take take some piece of formal
mathematics
and try to try to learn how it is done
so at the time i
used
something called inductive logic
programming ilp
which sort of
uh if it works which is hard because
it's sort of combinatorial search it
sort of gives you explainable rules of
how
how the mathematicians are doing their
proofs so so i think
uh that that sort of failed or it didn't
work for all sorts of reasons at the
time but it looks like in the
combination with the like strong
statistical machine learning methods
people are sort of coming back uh to
this today and i can really show you
some examples
uh
why do this today like there are well i
i guess patrick will talk about it and
christian also something so so people
really formalize
interesting theorems so so like probably
the canonical example for some time is
uh tom hill's proof of the couple
conjecture
which
was an open problem for 400 years then
tom and a student proved it in 1998
using
a lot of computation basically and the
proof was
not really easily checkable by by
mathematicians
uh and they they basically failed they
said like
we cannot 100 percent review and proof
check this so so tom
decided to do it
fully formally
and like after some like
16 oh they started in 2000 so maybe 10
12 years
the the proof was actually done in the
whole and
isabelle systems so so it's like that i
would say the most impressive example
for for mathematicians
uh but but there are many other today so
so george gender
this
uh phi thomson theorem in 2012 and his
team which is like two two graduate
books in
group theory
and and people do all sorts
of like
industrial
verifications like
they they verify a compiler like this
concert
or an operating system microkernel
etc etc so so it's it's really in
industrially the technology
is becoming sword of nature
and then there are all these crazy
crazy ai visions that i already
mentioned
oh
this is
so my
colleague in
the netherlands fake video
wrote uh more than 10 years ago
or like 20 years ago a comparison of the
different proof styles of proof
assistance and he starts with this like
very simple informal proof by hardin
wright about the rationality of square
root of two so so this is the
informal thing that all of you saw
and then he sort of gives the example of
the different form of profession so so
this is called declarative true style
which was sort of pioneered by the mizar
system
where you you sort of
basically mirror the structure of the of
the informal
sort of natural language natural
deduction proof
and then what you saw from christian
is a very different proof
than done in whole light where you apply
tactics so so so this is sort of a proof
script
in the whole light system
and and this is something in between
some something where you sort of combine
uh combine the two things when it's
mostly declarative but you have the
power to to use some longer
tactical uh like some sort of
chaining of um
theorem improving procedures to to help
you to
discharge
the thing so so
again like th this is a field that has
been born like some 60 years ago and
people have done quite a lot of these
things in in various ways
the this is the capital conjecture
about the optimal packing
of balls in space and as i said it's
been through
the proof was big
and if you
if you if you look at these uh things
like th this is actually formally
written in all light so it says that if
s is a polyhedron and c is the face of
the polyhedron then sees also the
uh polyhedron so so so one of the things
we did quite early like in 2014 was to
take this relatively big corpus of like
some 20 25 000 lemmas
and we showed but that by a relatively
cheap
machine learning methods like this was
like before the deep learning craziness
you you can like when you sort of
combine it with the existing or mildly
improved automated theorem provers
already
automatically prove
of of that
of that thing so so that that was like
one of one of the good signs that like
so sort of these combinations of
learning and
theorem brewing are
meaningful and useful to to the people
who try to
try to formalize
think this things percent this is
proving 40 percent of the dilemma that
have already been stated not not writing
any statements no no this wasn't doing
any conjecturing this is like what
what's
what is called the hammering scenario so
so that that became
popularized by larry paulsen especially
in the isabelle system
so so you have a proof assistant like in
the canonical example you you have very
lary possums isabel
and you
you are typically working in some sort
of more complicated logic than what your
automated theorem previous can do
so you need some sort of translation
that sort of takes the more complicated
logic
and translates it to to the simpler
logic that that's called a hammer and
the hammer also does other things like
selection of interesting
facts for proving your current
conjecture in
in your proof assistant
and then you you call all the automated
theorem proving slash ai technology
and if it gives you the proof you sort
of try to recover the proof in
uh in that sort of more
uh complicated uh logic that you are
working in so so this this became
i would say quite popular and it's it's
been sort of done
probably in all systems but lean i guess
uh
gradually
so like i said like
like in 2014-13 we had like 40 45
percent success
on these like professional libraries
and like with more and more machine
learning put into like the automated
theorem previous
we could do last year about 60 percent
of of the miza live library so i'll show
you uh some things about it
uh in in general like here is a bit of
an overview like what are all the ways
how people have done some
machine learning slash ai combinations
with
in the sort of theorem proving context
so you can you can do these very high
level things when when you sort of just
learn how to select lemmas from the
library that already contains a lot of
proofs
or you can do like very low level things
like guiding an automated theorem
preview that is doing really the very
very low level
modus ponens style inferences which is
sort of expensive because the
like i know the neural networks
especially are very slow compared to to
the fast symbolic solvers
then then there is this very reasonable
mid-level thing which christian was
already showing where you sort of guide
some
application of the blocks of the
reasoning
blocks tactics that the humans already
pre-programmed so so it's in some sense
it's sort of cheating compared to the
lowest level because you sort of rely on
on the humans to to sort of pre-create
uh
useful useful blocks but but it's
it works right like once the humans have
done something useful why why not use it
and support the humans even more
and then you you can go like into this
like fully
ai scenarios like theory exploration
means that you get some initial axioms
then you have some sort of
conjecturing system
that uh
tries to sort of develop this theory
and as it proposes new conjectures
it sort of tries to prove them or
disprove them and maybe it's sort of
slightly targeted in the sense that
there is some ultimate conjecture in the
end so we
almost cannot do that to today
or
like these feedback loops like this surf
alpha zero star feedback loops that you
sort of learn from your own successes
and repeat that at museum
scenes are very interesting
and christian already mentioned this of
the formalization where we would sort
of take kind of archive or all the math
and physics textbooks
and and turn them into a thing that the
computer can proof check so so that
that's like
that that actually seems today
more doable than i thought when we
proposed it like eight years ago
oh okay let's get to the demos let me
start looking at the time
oh
so
um
a very
oops this is work
can i copy
i really need to do
oh yeah so so this one is fairly simple
uh
so so um
oh yeah maybe maybe i should give you
a bit of context first
oh so so
um
so we have a uh
i'm doing a drunk
presentation
so so we have this enigma system which
which is basically
putting
a lot of
machine learning methods starting from
very fast ones
to to very slow and
sort of ai
uh deep learning ones into like the
state-of-the-art automated theorem
preview called improver
and uh we we run it on
on a reasonably big corpus of
mathematical proofs like this sort of
miser mathematical library
and and we basically run this in this
brewing learning group in many
iterations
so
uh when when we sort of started it when
we
finally got something that started to
work
we
uh
we uh
ran the initial
unguided unmodified automated theorem
preview
in 10 seconds over the whole corpus of
something like 60 000
problems
and it could prove about 15 000 of them
and then we trained the the sort of i
don't know neural networks and in this
case it actually aren't neural networks
these these are gradient booster trees
which are sort of much faster than
neural networks and
very very competent
uh and uh put it
put it into the theorem prove it to
guide the inferences the the choice of
what
what uh inference the the system should
do and then we run it again basically on
the full library
and in the first iteration like we run
it in two different modes like one is
standalone one is when we combine it
with the original system
it can sort of
improve
the performance quite a bit so so it
cannot like in in this case
some 6 000 uh new new theorems proved
and then then we train it again like on
on on these new theorems etc
and we iterate this i know about six
times and then in the end we we get a
system that can prove like 70 percent
more of
of the problems in the library in 10
seconds like no cheating no no hiding of
the neural network somewhere on your
server etc etc in in real time uh so so
that that that was like the the initial
uh sort of
priming of of the
uh of the um
of the sort of learning slash brewing
brewing club
and then then we sort of continued with
that
forever for for about
one more year
and we went
in we were sort of doing all sorts of
modification and doing it in all sorts
of ways
from this 25 000
uh
to
like more than 40 000
i think now we have like
uh 75 percent of of the
uh of the missouri library
and like here is uh one for one that is
looking simple but like um we only got
it when we started to do this like we
couldn't get it before
and it's just proving the pythagorean
theorem in any product spaces
so i'll show you
uh
show you the the thing how it looks like
in in the human
formalization so it says like you have a
real unitary space
you have two points or vectors that are
orthogonal
and then you do the sum you take the
norm and square it and it equals
the norm of x squared plus the norm of y
squared
and it's it's all like this human proof
is doing everything that
some i don't know first
second year student
taking the lecture about
hilbert spaces would be doing so he
expands
the definition of orthogonality to to be
that the scalar product is zero
and then he says that the the scalar
product is
always positive because of the
definition of scalar product
etc etc etc
at some point he uses the definition of
orthogonality and he concludes the the
final thing after after doing a lot of
these equations
so so this is i don't know like 15
15 line proof done in miser by a human
and uh so what what you want uh from
from the ultimate theory fear
improvement at this point
is like it it sees
the whole previous library at this point
which which may be
i don't know like maybe 20 30 000 facts
and definitions in in the library
so so you want first want it to select
the sort of good suspicious
statements in the library like like the
definition of scalar product etc etc so
so that that's this sort of premise
selection task
so in this case it
it chose uh 342
out of these like 20 30 000 by by by
doing this sort of machine learning from
from the previous brews that are already
there in in the library
and on top of these uh
you you now start some inferencing
process so you
so you want to combine them in such a
way
that you reach reach the conclusion
and that's a that's a crazy
uh combinatorial process that typically
leads uh
leads nowhere in in
most hard cases and and that that's
where the sort of machine learning
guidance is helping you
so so in this in this case
what i'm showing you is the
automated proof like found by by this
like learning guided uh theorem preview
which took something like 200 steps so
so the final
proof
done by the machine and in full
precision in full detail
is like
i don't know ten times longer
than the sort of human proof that you
see here because the
the sort of
machine found proof the
the sort of proof that is found by the
automated theorem
needs to be much more detailed in in
various ways though because
the the proof checker
has some sort of intelligence of its own
so so you can you can
whenever you say that this follows
from this by this definition
it it has some sort of auto completion
properties and it can infer a bit by
itself so so that's where you get the
blow up between
the the sort of um
low level thing where you really need to
finish the proof perfectly and and the
human level thing that gets partially
autocompleted
uh
what would be yeah so uh so that's the
final thing so so let's say it takes
like 200 steps
and out of this 340
it only used for the proof 34.
so that that's also interesting like you
you have some approximate intelligence
telling you like from the 20 30 000 that
we're preceding this formula
uh i am guessing that these three four
two
might be good for the proof
but it's still very approximate and the
real proof takes only ten percent of of
of that so so that that's what you
reveal
only during the process of actually
doing the proof and and finishing
finishing the proof
and the whole thing
i took
about 4 000 iterations of some theorem
brewing group where you always choose
the new fact to infer with
and you sort of do inferences with the
things that you already
decided are sort of the good facts that
that you you should
be inferring and during this process
you generate something like 60 000
facts all of that in about 30 30 seconds
so so these are how these machines work
today
like they generate quite a lot of stuff
on the other hand like if you for
example compare it with the machine
learning architectures these are
relatively small numbers so if you for
example look at what like christian was
saying about transformer if you see
how many
[Music]
like layers and how big are the layers
and how big is what one today calls an
inference of of these large
architectures
these are small numbers compared to like
one billion parameters in the
transformer but but it works uh sort of
fairly
fairly differently uh so so that's at
least one example to introduce you to to
this sort of uh stuff
uh i
uh
let me see if i want to show
something more yeah maybe this one is
interesting
so so almost like at the
at the end of this loop we also run
a version of another theorem prove a
vampire
which is like even stronger than epriver
because it has small
more heuristics in it
and
in in a long time in 500 seconds
it could prove
this
let me see if i can
maybe i'll click the wikipedia thing
here
um
it could prove basically this so so when
you when you have ordinal numbers inside
theory
oh well actually it's this one
so you you have the first order number
called epsilon zero that is like the
fixed point of exponentiation of omega
so so if you do omega to that ordinal
number you get
that number
and
uh
the the mesa proof is really
on on the level of being fairly
non-trivial so so so here you see the
miser statement and on the left-hand
side you say give me the first epsilon
ordinal number that is bigger than zero
and on the right hand side you see this
sort of tower of exponentiations like
omega two omega two omega
and
the the proof
is
non-trivial to to to say the least like
it's it's not
totally
uh impossible but but it takes uh quite
quite a while to to the human uh
formalizer
and the um
and the vampire proof
so so in this case there is some
statistics about it
so it takes 73 formulas
it only needs 49 of them
but the proof is like 1200 inferences
long so so so it's like
i know
six times longer than what i was showing
you before for this
pythagorean statement
it it does 40 000 iterations of this
basic in inference loop
and it generates like more than two two
million clauses
and and what is quite interesting here
so so so this is again a newly guided
very cheaply neutrally guided
architecture
where where the neural guidance because
it was done in a very smart way by
martin surah by my colleague takes only
20 seconds
and most of the problem solving is done
in sub solving because the the problem
can be split
into many many components by by sat
solver by by prepositional solver
and and basically
what what the neural model is doing is
trying to to say like this component is
easy this component is easy this
component is easy and then sort of
combine the results from the components
into into the like full
full proof and another big part of the
problem is congruence closure which is
sort of equation equation reasoning
so
and we couldn't get this proof
with the standard architecture
so so for example here the sort of
component splitting like like the
the fact that the this theorem can sort
of automatically
split itself into many cases and many of
them are easy and some of them are the
relevant ones
plays a big role here so so it sort of
also demonstrates
that uh
you you you sort of need these
combinations you you need these
algorithms
that take care of the combinatorial
parts of the program like uh very often
that helps you a lot like
in in the same way as i said that the
sat solvers are today superhuman in in
solving like the sort of discrete
combinatorial problems
doing architectures that sort of combine
such sort of superhuman
combinatorial uh
capability
with
the the sort of human style learning
because the neural
was sort of essential in in solving uh
solving this problem
so i'm almost out of time as usual
so i'll
yeah so so one thing uh
to
what
to show you
uh
for
uh for the conjecturing part
is
this so so it's sort of
like i guess uh
what what christians asked uh what was
that today you can use things like
transformers or recurrent neural
networks or whatever
uh to create
conjectures
so some two years ago i basically ran
the
sort of standard gpt
uh i trained it over a big uh corpus of
of mizar uh theorems and proofs
and
basically then i
was looking at like what new theorems i
can i can generate with it
and and one uh interesting thing that
that happened
was that
in in this case when you have a
in the library you you have a theorem uh
for finite groups
it's uh
in a very simple way just by omitting
the finiteness
the transformer generalized it to two
arbitrary groups
which was actually beyond our capability
of theorem brewing at that time so so we
we couldn't automatically prove it like
our ai tpe systems were too weak
so so i asked algebraics and then they
sort of
confirmed that this is actually
something that
they give to the students as they're not
totally true trivial truth in
in some first
or second lecture on group series but
but it sort of shows you like i guess
what christian was talking about
that at least to some extent like in
this case it's it's very simple you you
are just playing
with adding or removing assumptions
you you can use the
today's neural technology
to to generate conjectures that are
sometimes interesting
and
uh yeah here's another one uh so so i i
was asking the system
to prove that seconds is increasing on
that interval
and the gpd
decided to conjecture that every
differentiable function is increasing
good try
uh
so so so these conjecturing things they
they sort of split the problem into two
right like so so in this case
if you already know that this is true
then proving that other thing is easy
right but proving that this is true is
so sort of
not gonna work for you
and
maybe the last
demo that i'll show you
this one
um
so so
so in general like this conjecturing and
synthesis of interesting mathematical
objects is really
like one of the tasks that we
do not know how to do well
so thibault yeah who is this guy who did
a lot of interesting things recently in
this field
has spent his uh recent life uh working
with the integer sequences
uh so so he has
this system that is neurally guiding
synthesis of programs that explain
introduce integer sequences in
the online encyclopedia of integer
sequences by neil nielsen
and here i i gave it a bunch of primes
table
by some sort of neural guidance combined
with some sort of learning
of the semantics of the programs but
basically running the programs on the
first integers uh
learns to synthesize
more and more complicated
programs recursive functions etc like he
has a uh he is a sort of domain
a specific language for that which uh is
not totally
uh readable
well in this case it is quite readable
what did i do wrong here
these are not prime so there's 25 okay
i need to do more
let's try again
how does it know to you know match with
some
sequence from the library or not to just
do some pre-nomination for example
you mean could you just if then else
like on on the on the uh
it's how does it should match it with
integers for example
it's it's it's sort of discouraged to
cheat it you you could say that for
example if you
gave it like the first ten primes it
would come up with if then else
statement saying well if the input value
is one then return two if the input
value is is to return three et cetera et
cetera
but that program is actually longer than
than the program that
uh taboo generates here so so this is
this is the program
for quote uncle primes that he
discovered here
so so so the guiding
guiding heuristic for synthesizing these
things
is that it's okay okay razer basically
to to have the the program
as simple as possible because then you
believe that it sort of generalizes
right how does simple is defined how
simple yeah in in the domain specific
language so for example you do not have
real numbers available
you you have only numbers 0 1 and 2 i
think and then then you have some some
operations on on top of that
so so doing like some polynomial
over real numbers would would be
expensive for him
uh so so here
uh the program that he synthesized in
python looks like that and you
you might think that these are primes
but actually
they are not even though i was really
telling table forever like please and
then the primes for me
and
what what the machine
did in this case is fairmont studio
primes
and and the the oeis is designed in such
a way
that it's almost impossible to improve
to invent primes because the pseudo
primes differ from from the primes only
somewhere on this position the three
three four one
and the
the primes
are in oeis
only
up to
position 58 so you don't see the three
four one here the first difference this
is zero grams
but uh what we did
to to overcome this evilness of
fate
was to try
the character characteristic function of
the primes
which i believe is this one
no maybe it cannot
let's see
and it can do this one
and the
the sort of fairly
interesting thing
is that none of us understood why
this invented function defines times
like we needed a mathematician to tell
us that it's actually based on something
called the wilson
wilson theorem
um which which says something about how
you how you characterize prime
so
um
so the the point uh and i'm almost
finished here
is
um
is is that
like like this system
in my mind is some sort of
way forward from from these crazy
memorizing models
that do not compute they they are not
urine completely like they they do a lot
of statistical reasoning like the
ironmans and
uh the transformers
but like this system is like one of the
first approaches
for generating
like recursive functions like like the
things that are not typically
too much in the world of the statistical
neural machine learning people
but are very much in the minds of the
mathematicians and the programming
people like writing some fibonacci
sequence etc etc
and combining it with the sort of
statistical guidance for
synthesizing these objects
and maybe like gradually leading to even
some combined architectures that for
example you will have a neural network
that has some
like symbolic execution some sort of
computing or reasoning
bit in it that will help it to to do the
tasks that are like very hard for for
for the
purely purely neural systems today
so i think i have eaten all of my time
so this the rest of the sites is for
uh for for the next talk
and
if you as i said in the beginning
we have a friendly friendly conference
this aitp that is actually happening
this year again in france in september
and mike is our valued co-chair
taking care for ai tp for for physics
and
happy birthday to you mike and i hope
that
we will have as much fun as
we all have doing all these things and
that you will evangelize all these
physicists here to to come and
conquer conquer physics by
machine learnings you're improving and
artificial intelligence thank you
[Applause]
yeah yeah very nice talk uh i mean your
your automatic systems at this point
tend to when they work they generate
longer groups and i wonder have you
looked much at uh taking a proof that
works and shortening it or simplifying
it to automatically do that
yeah so so there are
the the there is this effect that
christian already mentioned that really
appeared for the first time my phd sees
us in 2004 that you can really find many
many shorter alternative proofs from
from different premise selections and
this has really appeared
throughout the history many times so so
that's one thing like like just
playing with the ai system that selects
the facts from the library and i even
like ten years ago when i
had the first system working over mizai
because i'm reviewing the mizar
submissions to to the library
i
i wrote a system that for me as an
external reviewer of some misa formal
article
runs the system over it
and tells me
that this proof could be shortened and
then i look very smart telling the
author who my reviewing
this proof should be shortened so it's
like for me as a reviewer that that's
sort of
uh a i
made me look smart
the the other thing was actually this
proof that i was uh showing
uh from from the vampire world
uh so i think it might have been
this one yeah
so
um
so this one
in this first
run that we got it that
martin sure got it took 500 seconds
but for example we have methods like
that again predate like the deep
learning it's some sort of symbolic
regression methods
that generate suitable strategies for
these automated theorem previews
and if you if you play
with various combinations of these
components that the um
complicated theorem preview is doing
then he can reduce this to 10 of the
running time so it's
it's not that the final proof would be
much shorter the final proof is sort of
similar
but but instead of
generating
2 million redundant clauses
you only generate i know five hundred
thousand 300 clauses
uh so
the the systems that
that we do are in some sense very often
motivated to produce short proofs
because we run run the systems with time
limit and we want to get more and more
of the harder and harder proofs
and i i guess a big thing of what is
happening is that the machine learning
becomes smarter and smarter
in like learning how to do the boring
part that it already knows how to do
and and focusing on on the new parts
that it still doesn't know how to do so
i would say that
the compression of the search is somehow
implicit in in the task
but
uh
i i would need to look at examples to to
to sort of
prove to you that i am right that
i i can also give you the opposite uh
reasoning so so we have systems that are
guided
symbolically
and
some people like bob vera are proving
open algebraic conjectures with them
and they work by
symbolic matching of dilemmas in the
previous proofs
and i have the experience that
when this works it sort of can guide you
to
to the goal by a very very long way
and if you do things in a brute force
way you you you will get a much shorter
proof
by an unguided theorem through so so so
the brute force
brute force has the advantage of go
going white and possibly short
the smartness and the scans can take you
in in this case can take you very long
and give you a long proof so so it's
it's to contradict myself you can do
both
it's complicated what is similar tpi
so uh one one example from 2008
when i wrote
one of this first system for premise
selection for this feedback loop between
selecting facts from the library and
proving more and more theorems using the
right selecting facts
i it was purely syntactic it was looking
at the features
of the mathematical objects at the like
symbols and in the formulas for example
you you look at the conjecture you want
to prove you look at the symbols of it
you look at the symbols of the other
things that you already proved and then
you do some sort of similarity metric
based on the symbol so so that that
would be like very symbolic
whereas
what what you can do also
is to take as a characterization of a
formula
the set of models in which the formula
holds
so
you can
in what we are doing
when you want to prove a formula from
some axioms if the axioms are not
sufficient if they do not have
sufficient logical power you can very
often find a counter model finite
counter model
that demonstrates that the axioms hold
in that counter model and the negation
of the conjunction also holds there so
that tells you this is a example and you
cannot get through like you will never
prove this
so so if you if you generate a lot of
these counter models
you can basically for each formula
give it
a
characteristic vector
of valuations in your finite modes
because you can just evaluate there like
imagine you you have many different
groups and you have a group theoretical
statement and now you say oh in this
group it is true and this group is false
etcetera etcetera and this is like a
very different characterization of the
formula which i call semantic in this
case
then the symbolic one when you just
take the parse tree of the formula
through it to to some graph neural
network or whatever it does some
convolutions
but it doesn't have the chance
to do the combinatorial thing that the
model
evaluators are doing like typically they
are based on such solvers so so it's
it's a it's a very combinatorial task
especially if you have
many quantifiers in the formula
to see whether the formula is true or
false in the model so so
you could try to learn it from the
syntactic structure and we actually are
sort of trying it
but it's uh
it's it's very
um difficult like
compared to to the tools that are
sort of targeted for this so in general
you you could say that
whenever you have some smart technology
based on some intelligent mathematics
like for example for groups or loops you
can have many advanced theorems
telling you
that i don't know a loop has some
property for example so so whenever you
use this knowledge i would use it i
would call it like a semantic
characterization of your mathematical
objects
rather than this sort of very
straightforward like syntactic symbolic
characterization of your objects
[Music]
you